- All right.
This next guest is a
platinum-selling artist
with 10 Grammy nominations to his name.
In a couple weeks,
he's starting his
coast-to-coast, 19-city tour
supporting his newest
album, "Joy in the Morning."
Now performing the title
song from his new album,
give it Up for Tauren Wells, y'all.
(audience cheering and clapping)
(slow soulful music)
♪ Everything happens for a reason ♪
♪ But you don't know what you don't know ♪
♪ And you'll never have peace ♪
♪ If you don't let go of tomorrow ♪
♪ 'Cause it ain't even faith
till your plan falls apart ♪
♪ But you still choose to follow ♪
♪ If it doesn't make sense right
now, it will when it's over ♪
♪ There will be joy in the morning ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ Giving in to your feelings is
like drowning in the shadows ♪
♪ Whoo ♪
♪ Oh, you gotta keep believing ♪
♪ Even in the middle
of the unknown, yeah ♪
♪ 'Cause grace will be there ♪
♪ When you come to the end
of your rope and you let go ♪
♪ It may feel like you're goin' down now ♪
♪ But the story isn't over ♪
♪ There will be joy in the morning ♪
♪ Hold on, hold on till the morning ♪
♪ Whoo ♪
♪ If it's not good, then He's not done ♪
♪ No, He's not done with it yet ♪
♪ There will be joy in the morning ♪
♪ Hey, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah ♪
♪ If it's not good, then He's not done ♪
♪ No, He's not done with it yet ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ If it's not good, then He's not done ♪
♪ No, He's not done with it yet ♪
♪ No, no, no ♪
♪ If it's not good, then He's not done ♪
♪ No, He's not done with it yet ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ If it's not good, then He's not done ♪
♪ No, He's not done with it yet ♪
♪ There will be joy in the morning ♪
♪ Hold on, hold on till the morning ♪
♪ Yeah, whoo ♪
♪ If it's not good, then He's not done ♪
♪ No, He's not done with it yet ♪
♪ Hey ♪
♪ There will be joy in the morning ♪
♪ And there will be joy in the morning ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
(audience cheering and applauding)
- All right, once again,
give it up for Tauren Wells.
(audience cheering and applauding)
Pick up his new album,
"Joy in the Morning"
wherever you get your music
and look online to find tickets
for his nation-wide tour
starting January 26th.